You
remember that translator funny little
lad one eye
i remember the ash you used to score got
your sew off your t*ts you ran through
albacerat naked as a jay bird
no mate that was you oh
of course was it yeah cheers
so what sort of extraordinarily deep
sh*t are you in that you come
shuffling up to my door in the middle of
the night i thought maybe you could help
me
find her
tasty who is she it's me wife
someone married you yeah 'fraid so
i thought maybe you could put some
feelers out you know get some of the old
intel boys
higgins esquera all respect yay
doesn't seem to me like your girl wants
to be found
look are you gonna you know me or not
of course i am we're mates are we
ordering pizza are we take it easy mate
plotters are on their way you shouldn't
have done that chuck
you top that stilwell woman on the telly
you're gonna top your wife as well
i didn't kill no one okay my billy
i'll see what you can do like a ragged a
squirt gun
now you're a killer down in the ground
that don't change
A train you're out out of what out of
seven
how many more people have to die what
are we gonna do
we're gonna sit around and cross our
fingers that homelander's gonna save us
i'm at my wits end i'm in the face of the
seven not you
wait, I found becca vought facility armed
to the teeth
won't be easy
Welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my video for the boys
season 2
short movie obviously this is all about
butcher's character it's meant to fill
in that gap of time
in episode 1 before he shows up but
after homelander dumps him in that
parking lot
we've also got a bunch of footage from
the next couple of episodes so we'll
break it all down there's a bunch of
easter eggs if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get
everything
obviously my episode 4 video will post
tomorrow too
careful for spoilers for everything
that's happened on the boys so far
but just starting at the beginning of
this footage i'll talk about the short
movie stuff in the easter eggs first
then i'll talk about the trailer footage
so like i said it starts with butcher
being dumped in the parking lot of that
family restaurant a couple of states
away
just because homelander is mean like
that he literally flew him a couple
states away just to dump him in the
middle of nowhere
they have that awkward comedy of the
hostess seeing him on the news broadcast
while he's frantically writing down
details of becca's whereabouts with the
crayon on the menu
then he takes off hot wires a car and
takes it to his old squad mate's house
from the military
i can't tell if they're supposed to be
kiwis or australians based on their
dialect
but it should be clear from the way that
they talk to each other about their
history together in the picture of them
from the war
that they fought together for australia
for new zealand either in iraq or
afghanistan
the boys comic book was actually being
published while all those wars were
going on 10 plus years ago
so the war references that it made were
to older wars the boys tv show because
it's happening now has just been moved
up in the timeline a little so it
references more recent conflicts
they said that they were filming this
during the first couple of episodes but
it just didn't work
inside the episode that they wanted to
put it in so they just turned it into
its own short movie by itself
but pretty much the same thing that
happened at the restaurant happens
between butcher and his former squad
mate
his squad mate hears vots fake story
being broadcast about butcher killing
stillwell which we know didn't happen on
the news
and believes it rather than believing
butcher he says it's because he saw what
butcher did during the war just implying
that he was
super hardcore when they were in the
military and because this is all
supposed to be happening before the
events of episode 2 and 3
where butcher went crazier and crazier
on huey even threatening to kill him
if anyone else got in his way of trying
to find becca you can kind of see how
this would have helped set that up a
little bit more explaining more of
butcher's backstory and how he used to
be
really really crazy in the war there's
this whole idea that they were setting
up in the first couple of episodes about
butcher getting darker and darker his
methods getting more and more hardcore
just like homelander getting more and
more wtf it's just that the first couple
of episodes homelander was doing that
with milk
getting crazier and crazier with the
milk which somehow seems even worse than
all the stuff that butcher is doing and
him
beating the crap out of the marvel
daredevil parody character in lasering
all those random people left and right
but speaking of milk mother's milk
literally has that conversation with
butcher in the tunnels during episode 3
about him going too far
so it's more a question of what's going
to happen once they do find becca
because there is footage in that episode
4 trailer of becca on the street looking
like she might wind up being reunited
with butcher pretty soon or at least
they find out where she is
but moving into the footage from the
rest of the season that they have in the
trailer here it mostly focuses on hyping
the inevitable confrontation between
homelander and stormfront in vaught's
tower here
but stormfront has this rally where it
seems like she starts stoking the
people's fears
trying to get the public to demand
vaught use more compound b
to create even more superheroes to
protect them from the quote-unquote
super villains that are coming to get
them
the totally fake super villains that we
know that vot is inadvertently creating
because they were also created with the
same compound v
that voc controls remember the whole
thing here is that the public is getting
ready to turn on
vaught unless they talk real fast now it
seems like stormfront has this plan to
do that to get the public to demand
that they create more supers so it's a
good thing now suddenly that they have
compound v
but homelander doesn't know anything
about this she's playing this
four-dimensional chess game that he just
doesn't totally understand
so homelanders watching this broadcast
of her thinking that she's calling him
out like he won't be able to save them
you think homeland is going to be able
to save you
as if she's calling him impotent or
something like that challenging his
supremacy
but clearly it's just her playing the
public like a fiddle in order to help
vaught remember the whole thing in the
first couple of episodes is just
revealing how much of a degenerate she
really is
she's a full-blown neo-nazi somehow
she's even worse
than home later all the crazy stuff that
we've seen him do so it just seems like
this fight between the two of them
comes to a boil before she reveals what
she's really doing
the long game that she's really playing
and it seems like he probably winds up
enjoying that quite a bit
you have to imagine he's probably going
to be super turned on by all of her
kinks
and think about what a degenerate she is
and what kind of kinks that she has if
homelander has all these crazy milk
kinks
it also seems like homelander wants to
kick a train out of the seven and maybe
that's how he winds up in this scene
here from the trailer hanging out with
the deep in the middle of nowhere ohio
he also has that whole side plot with
starlight going on where they're both
caught in a lie
trying to hide it from the rest of the
seven and clearly on the other side of
that
homelander has had it with starlight
because of what happened in the tunnels
he doesn't trust her at all so she's
also on thin ice there's been a lot of
questions about which people within the
seven will help
turn to the boys and help them take down
the rest of the seven and bought there's
just a couple characters that could go
either way at this point including queen
maeve
they also hype up kimiko vs stormfront
for the rest of the season
the way the actors talk about it the
boys and butcher are all focused on
becca getting her back and taking down
the seven and vaught for good
but kimiko clearly doesn't care about
any of that she only cares about ripping
stormfront in half for killing her
brother
and clearly does not mind trying to go
after her in broad daylight in the
middle of this crowd
so this will be interesting just going
after her while she's on national
television in a crowd full of people
then it seems like butcher finally
learns where becca is exactly but it's
not really clear if they meet up at the
end of the episode or if it's going to
happen in a future episode
because she's on cctv footage here it
seems like she's still somewhere in the
suburbs so she hasn't made it out of
this sort of compound area
that she's stuck in with her son i'm
still really fascinated to see what's
going to happen between homelander and
his son as well because it definitely
seems like he's burned or is burning
that bridge
and if there's anyone that's going to be
powerful enough to fight him it would be
his son
but clearly his son doesn't completely
know about his powers yet but just a big
reminder my episode 4 video and easter
eggs will post on friday
each of the rest of the episodes through
the finale will air once per week each
friday
but as long as you have alerts enabled
for my channel you'll see all those
videos when i post them so no worries it
seems like most people were able to find
my episode 1 through 3 video
over the course of last week everyone
click here for that video
and then click here for my brand new
chadwick boseman black panther 2 video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!